amazing if you want some inspirational
quotes when you travel why not
we're traveling to New York then San
Francisco then LA gonna do more fun
tours stuff things and you brothers are
coming along
number 21 why is it number not number
one at least it's not in the children's
chart this is serious over here this is
for kids
awesome okay so this is the space I will
be up there I can go okay well I can go
there's gonna be a thousand five hundred
people which is more than the other ones
and the other ones are already insane so
I hope I will make it out alive today is
the day if you thought the other events
were crazy maybe you didn't I don't know
I think they're crazy today it's gonna
be the craziest it's the biggest one
there's even a stage and I'm doing some
PR this morning I'm really nervous
although I gotta say I look I look good
I look I'm working it look at this
flawless so we're at a bar Kade I'm
gonna do quick interview
I never bitter a bar code before it
looks awesome and ugly
No thank you sit down let's do this
yes meet you ha ha and we're playing the
game that you actually created it's
called the brofist yeah just wrapped up
the interview we're done with all the
interviews and now we're gonna go do the
signing thing yes you're coming ok
awesome look cuz all the way around
you're very very casual line but this is
the money I'll get out first
ready for madness
yeah I'll stay in that how do I left
yeah that beautiful the K I'm feeling
okay
this is sneaking behind the books they
don't know where we are
No
we finished 1500 breasts I'm so tired
can you tell I can think you can tell
from my voice it's gone really fun
really heartwarming and I'm just ready
to go home and go to sleep right now
how's it going we are in LA because
there's palm trees that's the only way
you would know another signing today in
actually 15 minutes this one is a little
shorter which I'm happy about because
six hours to talk and meet people
constantly very exhausting it's been so
intense so far it's just crazy what
we're doing to be honest but I think
we'll look back on it and we'll be
that's great there are some pictures I
want to show you we had a professional
photographer doing the picture for the
Meetup
really funny ah it was a duck sword
everyone kept asking no rest all right
all right all right
a lot of people they must be looking for
me I feel so sneaky shocking way there
we go this is Rick's tiny design yes
you'll be there hey you okay there's
more apparently great I'm walking over
hey how's it going hi everyone
actually this was the smoothest one so
far by far what a difference we're
getting good at this
it's really crazy like I said what we're
doing with the meetups
I'm just really jet-lagged and really
tired so tomorrow we have the day off
tomorrow is Halloween I'm really excited
it's gonna be fun and I'll see you
tomorrow
hey are you doing today I'm doing the
photo shoot because I'm a model no
because we're doing promotional stuff
for scare PewDiePie why don't you come
on out and 40 minutes later we are here
yay should we try without every tire
cover yeah right yeah left with red
that's great
the Lighting's so castle satin looks old
but it smells new it's definitely and
get that time [ __ ] off that reason
okay there here we go ah yeah there we
go
no yeah we agreed down close Natalie
this is wool oh well there you go your
eyes yeah yeah that's great that ayah
was awesome
all right out right all right it's
Halloween guess my outfit it's a movie I
look like a gangster it's one it's one
of my favorite movies I don't think it
worked out really well I should have
tried it before
we are so tired and we're gonna leave
early tomorrow we were invited to a
party but we might not go we'll see
we're gonna eat and that's we'll see hey
how's it going okay we're in San
Francisco now last second last day of
the tour I did go to the party last
night so I am a little tired and we're
chilling for an hour and then the thing
starts yes from you guys so I'm gonna
answer my Maria see if you got another
animal plant what would it be and what
would
amen Edgar is enough like I don't I want
to get rid of him first
right okay that's all you get
take me Oh
that was the book tour I have one more
I'm actually going to Sweden but this
was generally it it was crazy
I did not expect when I said I was gonna
do a book tour that it was going to be
this insane it was really cool to meet
you Bros and see who you are in person I
was really surprised by how had such a
wide range of different type of people
from really young to like way older than
me to find girls to find boys to people
who just wanted to thank me for making
the videos and and them you know stories
about how they helped in tough times or
just general positivity really really
amazing
it was way crazier than I felt like this
whole thing like this a thousand five
hundred people to to go through and now
it's a lot I had a blast I would
definitely do it again without
hesitation and I just again want to say
thanks to everyone who came and waited
for hours just to meet me I really
really appreciate it we are in Japan
alga Japanese garden San Francisco our
plane is at 7:30 so we're just macrosse1
yes no you can't can you
Marseilles brain I am bring - okay it's
not too bad every yeah how do you get
down oh good
look at that oh yeah that's the spot
ah I think someone is in love
Oh No I found the enemy I'm here how my
children
okay you can't see me
we're in a boat yes really enjoying San
Francisco this time around
really nice place I'm glad we had the
day off to explore it this is this is
awesome
how's Umbra is is beautifu so I'm in
Sweden and doing my final book turning
book book tour here it's gonna be
awesome and I'm excited
this is for my Swedish
we've done most of them I think and look
who's here do you want to be involved
yeah I can Patti's in the back yes we
look the same everyone says we look the
same
broken yeah all the people out there you
going breaks roughest in three all right
yeah so the book tour is over I'm still
in Sweden I'm leaving in just a few
minutes but I wanted to show you since
I'm home
maybe pewds I don't think I should show
these I don't know if it's a good idea
there's me so cute look at me I'm
censoring my penis with my finger
there's daddy
well that's all you get for now am i
right I ran around all right
that was this another adventure gun
final thanks to everyone who came the
book tours are it's super shaky as I'm
damn recording my iPad just want to make
outro angel earthquake Oh
brofist